you're loved by many people here in
Israel and in the world but you're also
hated by many in fact I think you may be
one of the the most hated men in the
world so if there's a young man or a
young woman listening to this right now
who have such hate in their heart
what can you say to them to
one day turn that hate into love I
disagree with the premise of your
question uh I think I have uh have
enjoyed a very broad support around the
world there are certain uh Corners in
which we have uh we have this animosity
that you describe and it sort of
permeates in some of the uh the
newspapers and the News organs and so on
in the in the United States but it
certainly doesn't reflect the the broad
support that I have I just gave
an interview on an Iranian Channel
16 million viewers I gave another one I
just did a a little video a few years
ago 25 million viewers from Iran
certainly no hate there I have to tell
not from the regime okay and when I go
around the world and I've been around
the world uh people
I want to hear what we have to say what
I have to say is the leader of Israel
whom they respect increasingly as a
rising power in the world so I uh I
disagree with that and the most
important uh thing that goes against
what you said is the respect that we
receive from the Arab world and the fact
that we've made four historic peace
agreements with Arab countries and they
made it with me they didn't make it with
anyone else and I respect them and they
respect me and probably more to come so
I think the premise is wrong that's all
well
there's a lot of love yes a lot of
leaders are collaborating our respect I
said not not though okay all right well
it's a spectrum
but there is people who
um don't have good things to say about
Israel who do have hate in their heart
and for Israel
and what can you say to those people
well I think they don't know very much I
think they're Guided by a lot of uh
ignorance they don't know about Israel
they don't know that Israel is a stellar
democracy that it happens to be one of
the most advanced societies on the
planet that what Israel develops helps
uh Humanity in every field in medicine
and Agriculture and uh in the
environment and
telecoms and
talk about AI in a minute but changing
the world for the better and spreading
this among uh six continents we've sent
rescue teams more than any other country
in the world and we're one tenth of one
percent of the world's population but
when there's a earthquake or a
Devastation in Haiti or in the
Philippines Israel is there when there's
an earthquake a devastating earthquake
in Turkey Turkey Israel was there when
there's something in Nepal Israel is
there and it's a second country it's the
second country after in one case India
or after another case the United States
Israel is there tiny Israel is a
benefactor to all of uh Humanity so
you're a student of History if I can
just Linger on that philosophical notion
of hate
uh that part of human nature if you look
at
uh World War II what do you learn from
human nature from the rise of the Third
Reich and the rise of somebody like uh
Hitler and the hate the premieres there
well what I've learned is that you have
to nip bad things in the bud you have to
uh there's a lot in terms that says
Lobster Pinkie Pie stop bad things when
they're small uh and the deliberate
hatred the the uh
incitement of hatred against uh one
Community this demonization
delegitimization that goes with it uh is
is a very dangerous thing and that
happened in the case of the Jews what
started with the Jews soon spread to all
of humanity so what we've learned is
that's what we should we should never
and I never set aside and say oh they're
just threatening to destroy us they
won't do it if somebody threatens to
eliminate you as Iran is doing today and
as Hitler did then and people discounted
it well if somebody threatens to an
eyelid well take them seriously and act
to prevent it early on don't let them
have the means to do so because that may
be too late
so in those threats
underlying that hatred how much of it is
anti-zionism and how much of it is
anti-Semitism I don't distinguish
between the two you can't say well I'm
okay with Jews but I just don't think
there should be a Jewish State it's like
saying I'm not anti-American I just
don't think there should be an America
that's basically what who what people
are saying these are the
anti-anti-semitism and anti-zionism uh
when you say anti-zionism you're saying
the Jewish people don't have a right to
have a state of their own uh and that uh
that is a denial of uh of a basic uh uh
a basic principle that I think
completely
unmasks what is involved here today
anti-Semitism is anti-zionism those who
oppose the Jewish people oppose the
Jewish state